pour fixer les quotas de pêche durable
les chercheurs doivent être capables de
déterminer
l'abondance d'une espèce mais
l'évaluation des stocks n'est pas une
science exacte
un bon exemple de ça c'est le thon rouge
ce poisson est un très grand migrateur
etc perpétuel déplacement compliquer la
tâche des scientifiques
[Musique]
on dit de ce poisson qu'il joue dans la
tête des pêcheurs qui les rend fous le
thon rouge de l'atlantique livre chaque
fois de furieux combats ceux qui
fréquentent les eaux canadiennes sont
les plus gros de leur espèce
dans les provinces maritimes ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas vu autant de
thon rouge au grand plaisir des pêcheurs
c'est le poisson parfait et l'effort il
est hydrodynamique les rapides coloris
aucun autre poisson n'a autant de
puissance brute
après des décennies de surexploitation
le thon rouge ce symbole mondial de la
surpêche serait-il désormais hors de
danger
l'abondance c'est ce que vit la
communauté de notre legs de l'île du
prince édouard qui se targue d'être la
capitale du ton boulot
traille bruce a même des touristes
pêcher le thon rouge à chacune de ses
sorties depuis quelques années ils
constatent que le grand migrateur est
bel et bien de retour
vous allez assez suvi mail au large ou
stopper le bateau est la première chose
que vous voyez c'est un banc de 200 ton
est ensuite un autre et encore un autre
plus loin ils sont partout joyent se
souvient des périodes de faible
abondance au milieu des années 80 les
pêcheurs ont même connu une disette de
neuf ans sans aucune capture de thon
rouge
ça nous a pris par surprise
ça a mis fin à un mode de vie auquel on
s'était habitué 1998 la commission
internationale pour la conservation des
thonidés de l'atlantique
la secte a confirme que le thon rouge
est bel et bien une espèce surexploitée
l'essor mondial des sushis a provoqué
une demande folle et engendrer une pêche
incontrôlée
des pêches illégales ont aussi donné un
dur coup à l'espèce
résultat la cicta et posera en 2008 de
sévères restrictions sur les pêches
aujourd'hui croyait d'avis que le stock
est reconstruit il affirme que les
mesures imposées sur la pêche ont tiré
l'espèce des griffes de l'extinction
la commission internationale des
thonidés a même autorisé une hausse des
quotas en 2018
[Musique]
je crois que le stock est en excellente
santé
on voit une grande variété de tailles
pourtant malgré les signes d'un retour
un doute subsiste sur l'abondance du
thon rouge
halifax
shannon arnold travaille pour un groupe
de défense de l'environnement elle
rentre d'espagne où elle a participé à
la dernière réunion internationale
dédiée à la gestion du thon rouge
pour cette spécialiste une grande
prudence doit encore guidé les
commissaires internationaux chargés
d'établir les quotas de pêche
nous sommes encore à de très bon niveau
si on les compare à ce que nous avions
autrefois même si nous observons une
tendance à la hausse ces dernières
années
nous restons en deçà de ce que nous
avions dans les années 70 nous devons
rester prudents c'est un prédateur
important pour nos océans
nous ne voulons pas répéter les erreurs
du passé dès qu'apparaissent les
premiers signes de rétablissement
cette prudence est aussi partagée par
les scientifiques canadiens à saint
andrews au nouveau-brunswick une équipe
de pêches et océans canada est chargé
d'étudier cette espèce et de faire des
recommandations à la commission
internationale des thonidés jusqu'ici
les données des chercheurs montrent bel
et bien que l'espèce remonte la pente
mais l'évaluation de son abondance
comporte encore d'énormes incertitudes
scientifiques
c'est incroyable ce que pu parcourir ce
poisson en migration les migrations de
cette espèce cause des maux de tête aux
chercheurs ces déplacements continuels
rendent difficile le recours aux
méthodes habituelles d'évaluation on a
marqué ce ton en septembre 2015 ou large
de la nouvelle écosse
on peut voir qu'il est demeuré près des
côtes ça lui a pris qu'un mois pour
parcourir toutes ses distances
cette traversée de l'atlantique a
surpris les chercheurs il ya quelques
années
depuis les migrations comme celle ci se
multiplient dans l'atlantique
on distingue deux stocks de thon rouge
selon leur lieu de naissance
le stock de l'est et celui de l'ouest
à l'ouest les tons naissent dans le
golfe du mexique
dès l'âge de 5 ans il remonte les côtes
américains et canadiens en été pour se
nourrir à l'est les temps vont plutôt se
nourrir sur les côtes européennes et
africaines
mais tous se retourne dans la mer
méditerranée pour se reproduire
les chercheurs ont toujours cru que les
mélanges entre ces deux stocks étaient
rares tellement rare qu'on a calculé et
fixer des quotas de pêche distincts pour
ces deux populations
mais les nouvelles migrations oblige les
chercheurs à revoir leurs calculs
cet homme veut déterminer la quantité de
thon issus de la méditerranée qui se
mélangent maintenant aux stocks de
l'ouest dhiraj vous à wang prélève de
petites pièces au seuil dans le crâne
des thons capturés par les pêcheurs
canadiens
l'analyse chimique de ces fragments lui
révèle le lieu de naissance des thons
pêchés
le spécialiste a non seulement démontré
que le mélange des tons et fraikin mais
surtout que ce phénomène prend de
l'ampleur et s'est beaucoup comparé à
une dizaine d'années c'est dans les
années 2010 ont la plupart de nos
poissons étaient d'origine est d'origine
du golfe du mexique
et maintenant c'est se dire dans les dé
dans les p ô trois dernières années
c'est à peu près 50% qui était bien dû
de la méditerranée
le mélange des stocks préoccupent de
plus en plus alex sink grand responsable
de la recherche sur les tons pour le
canada nous devons faire attention à ne
pas nous laisser induire en erreur
il se pourrait que plus de poissons se
concentrent dans nos zones et que nos
indicateurs montrent un accroissement de
la population
[Musique]
la prudence du chercheur s'explique par
le fait que ce sont surtout les tons de
la méditerranée qui visitent les côtes
canadiennes et non l inverse
on pourrait croire que le stock de
l'ouest est plus abondant qu'il ne l'est
en réalité
la commission internationale
auraient-elles surévaluent mais la
quantité de thon et les quotas de pêche
pour le stock de l'ouest celui qui
exploite les pêcheurs canadiens
sur ce point les chercheurs sont
rassurants les quotas de pêche canadiens
restent très faibles et pour l'instant
tous les indicateurs des scientifiques
montrent que les deux stocks continuent
leur remontée
autant ici qu'en méditerranée
toutefois ces nouvelles données mettent
en lumière l'interdépendance des stocks
européens et américains une réalité dont
devront tenir compte les gestionnaires
internationaux de cette espèce ce qu'on
dit aux commissaires
c'est que quelles que soient les
décisions que vous prenez pour le stock
de l'est cela aura probablement un
impact sur le stock de l'ouest
la commission internationale des
thonidés procédera en 2020 à sa
réévaluation des stocks de thon rouge
pour tout l'atlantique
historiquement les pêcheurs des 53 pays
membres ont toujours exercé de fortes
pressions pour que la commission relève
ses quotas de pêche au canada une
tendance inverse semble se dessiner
[Musique]
plutôt qu exiger de nouveaux quotas des
pêcheurs et des transformateurs cherche
à obtenir plus de valeur pour leurs
prises
[Musique]
jason tomkins est le principal acheteur
de thon rouge au pays
il nous accueille dans sa toute nouvelle
usine de nom plec traditionnellement les
pêcheurs ont toujours vendu des temps
entier aux acheteurs asiatiques mais les
bas prix des dernières années sur les
marchés
les force à revoir cette façon de faire
c'est le 350e tant que jason tomkins
achète cette saison aux pêcheurs de nos
plaies qu il veut bâtir avec eux une
industrie canadienne de la
transformation
il propose ou pêcheurs te découper leur
temps et de mettre en valeur chaque
partie du poisson c'est trop
levan tu ton rouge ça c'est le boeuf
kobe du l'océan les valeurs du sort
c'est presque 50 $ chaque livre japon
savoir montréal ça c'est le crew lyon
c'est très frais c'est très rouge c'est
parfait pour le marché canadien
en valorisant chaque capture ce
transformateur espère qu'on pourra
assurer l'avenir de cette pêche sans
augmenter les quotas faut prendre moins
du temps parlé de l'histoire contée
l'histoire c'est une espèce incroyable
magnifique on faut que les gens les
chairs qui restera savent ou d'où vient
sous ton et prendre moins ton mais
wendel pour pour plus d'argent
il est encore trop tôt pour parler d'une
pêche au thon rouge qui soit durable
mais les spécialistes s'entendent pour
dire que la surexploitation de l'espèce
est chose du passé
traille bruce mise quant à lui sur le
développement de la pêche sportive pour
protéger l'espèce il amène pêcher des
touristes mais la réglementation les
oblige à remettre à l'eau ne t'ont
capturer cette pêche est en plein essor
elle est même encouragé par les groupes
de défense du thon rouge
ça ne fait pas de sens de tuer ses tons
pour un ou deux livres
[Musique]
les pêcheurs de notre lake sont
maintenant conscients qu'ils ont
peut-être une dernière chance avec cette
espèce emblématique
ça fait partie de notre culture c'est
quelque chose qui je crois a bâti l'île
du prince édouard
[Musique]